en france en 2018 selon l'insee 14 7% de
la population vivait sous le seuil de
pauvreté
en d'autres termes 9 3 millions de
français gagner moi de 1065 euros par
mois un chiffre en hausse de 0,6 point
par rapport à 2010 est pourtant en 2018
la croissance s'établissait à 1,7 pour
cent cette dernière ne profiterait donc
pas à toutes les catégories de la
population les 20 % de français les plus
aisées détiennent en effet une masse de
revenus 4 4 fois supérieure aux 20% les
plus modestes
un écart en légère augmentation en 2018
alors qu'il était stable depuis 2013
cette hausse s'explique en partie par la
forte augmentation de certains revenus
comme les dividendes qui sont
principalement l'apanage des ménages
aisés d'autant qu'au 1er janvier 2018 en
traite en vigueur le prélèvement
forfaitaire unique plus connu sous le
nom de flat tax destinée à alléger
l'impôt sur ce type de revenus autre
explication à cette hausse des
inégalités la baisse des apl les aides
personnalisées au logement pour les
locataires des hlm qui représente
parfois plusieurs dizaines d'euros en
moins pour les ménages qui en
bénéficient à noter cependant que
l'insee ne prend pas en compte dans ses
calculs la baisse des loyers des
logements sociaux censés compenser cette
réduction des apl
cela dit même en retirant la baisse des
allocations logement de l'équation
la tendance reste inchangé il y à bien
également la baisse de la taxe
d'habitation ou encore la bascule des
cotisations chômage vers la csg mais ces
mesures ne bénéficie principalement
qu'aux ménages imposables donc au dessus
du seuil de pauvreté
d'autant qu'il ne faudrait pas oublier
que ces chiffres de l'insee ne concerne
que les revenus et oui les inégalités
sont encore plus criante lorsque l'on
observe le patrimoine toujours en 2018
et toujours selon l'insee les 10% les
plus aisés détenait 720 fois plus de
richesses que les 10% les plus pauvres
en résumé la croissance bénéficie
majoritairement aux ménages aisés
contribuent à creuser les inégalités et
ne permettent pas d'enrayer la pauvreté